In their most anticipated issue of the year,
"Sports illustrated" is unveiling a diverse
lineup of cover models, including, that is
Martha Stewart, folks, at 81 years young.
The business tycoon on the cover as well as
singer-songwriter Kim Petras, who is the magazine's
second transgender cover model and in a statement
"Sports illustrated" says while the industry
waivers on the arbitrary negotiation of beauty,
showcasing the women of today, the women shaping
the future.
So happy to bring in the editor and chief
of glamour, Sam berry, reinventing glamour
and showing all of the sides of beauty every
age, every shape, color.
Talk Martha Stewart.
>> I loved it.
I loved not only Martha, right, we can come
to her, 81 years of
[7:56:31 AM]
we can come to her, 81 years of age, the oldest
"Sports illustrated" swimsuit model cover
and I think it was interesting.
I saw it being shared all over social yesterday.
It was nice to see people saying she looks
good, so hot.
And they weren't using the qualifier for her
age because she looks hot, period.
>> She does.
>> If the domestic republic, it was shot.
We have seen the tease from Martha, on her
Instagram, put photos of her poolside.
What's nice about Martha, I think, she is
the mother of reinvention.
"The New York Times" said do not try to pinchle
hole her.
She had a catering business in the '70s, lifestyle
empire in the '90s, now snoop Dogg's bff and
now cover model.
>> Were you surprised?
>> No.
There was a
really defined what a cover star would look
like, a
[7:57:34 AM]
a cover star would look like, a certain age,
looked a certain way.
What you are seeing from "Sports illustrated"
yesterday on the covers, including age, size
diversity, they had a trans woman on the cover.
You are seeing that they are leaning in magazines
are representing what is happening in the
world around them and it's not this finite
version of what is sexy swimsuit model looks
like.
>> 1961, that's Martha Stewart.
>> A college woman of the year.
>> Yeah.
Also we are seeing a glamour, older women
covers do really well.
Last year we shot Jane fonda 60 years after
she was first shot for glamour.
A 98-year-old on the cover.
And what we are seeing not only the women
in the decades, '60s, '70s, '80s, the women
in their 20s want to know what they can learn
from these women, their life story.
Martha has a lot of life she is telling us
about.
[7:58:36 AM]
telling us about.
>> What are the lessons they have?
Most people think they know Martha Stewart
but you list add lot of things that aren't
as obvious about her.
>> She is so amazing at reinventing herself.
She has gone through trials and tribulations
in the past and I think she is -- she never
gets bored and I think she said in the "Sports
illustrated" story, if I am done changing
I'm done.
She is constantly change hg, constantly surprising
her audience.
She is one of these women that are good -- I
don't know if you follow her on Instagram.
>> I definitely follow her on Instagram.
Instagram is amazing.
She never takes herself too seriously.
>> Humor.
>> She will be like I had this amazing salmon,
caviar --
She is a home making guru, TV personality,
businesswoman, and snoop Dogg bestie.
Today, she has another title under her belt.
Martha Stewart is the oldest sports illustrated
swimsuit issue cover model, at 81 years old.
She is a mom for cover models this year, actress
Megan fox, model brooks Nader, and singer
Kim Petras join her.
Petras is the second transgender woman to
make the iconic issues cover.
Here has how Martha described her historic
moment.
>> To be on the cover at my age was a challenge,
and I think I met the challenge.
For me, it is a testament to good living.
And I think that all of us should think about
good living, successful living, and not about
aging.
I hope it does give people, women especially,
on
[1:52:16 AM]
women especially, on opportunity to revisit
their lives and get with the picture.
>> We call that living her best life.
Joining me now, sports illustrated swimsuit
editor in chief, mj de.
Thank you so much for joining us.
How did you decide, how did the Megan's inside
hey, what we have Martha Stewart on the cover?
>> Well, about two years ago, I'm sure you
may remember Martha posted a pretty provocative
thirst trap, they called it, of her coming
out of her pool in Bedford.
I will tell you, I never forgot that, and
I thought you know what?
Here is someone who really has it going on,
in more ways than one, and let's celebrate
it.
>> Were there any decisions made on the part
of Martha Stewart, like, did you say hey,
don't do this, don't you from this angle,
don't -- or did you have decisions like that
that had to be made?
>> Well, the beauty of what we do at sports
illustrated is it's really, really collaborative
effort between the talent and the photographer,
and of course myself.
I take that approach with everyone we work
with, but absolutely, we met with Martha many
times, going into this.
[1:53:16 AM]
many times, going into this.
You know, it's an important moment for her,
for her brand, for what she represents, and
we wanted her to feel her best and comfortable.
So you know, Ruben afinitor who is the photographer
that shot the cover was someone that Martha
had worked with previously, and someone that
I had worked with previously and equally adore.
She reviewed swimwear choices with us, and
we talked about everything.
She was a former model, you know, so she knows
her way around the camera, and it was a lot
of real, collaborative effort.
And Martha knows which he won.
So does Rubin, so do I, and I think we all
met in a beautiful place.
It was a really, really lovely experience.
>> I've got to tell, you mj, those pictures
are stunning.
I don't care how old she is, or whatever season,
I do want to ask you, if you got any blow
back, or got any criticism, or has all just
been praise?
>> I have only heard praise, and that gives
me so much joy,
[1:54:20 AM]
and that gives me so much joy, and I am so
happy to be able to say that, because I think
it is something that we as women need to hear,
and feel, and understand better.
Because there are so many things that we have
been told that we can and cannot do, and here
is someone who is living her life to the fullest,
and not knowing any, you know, any lines except
the ones she creates.
I think that's a great example for all of
us to follow, and it's been really great,
it's been really positive, it's been really
celebratory, and it really makes me happy,
as a woman myself, to feel that.
>> There's going to be a lot of people to
say about time, she's the first person, but
the first person over 80 years old, and she
looks amazing.
So thank you so much, mj de.
The issue is on new stands,